merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je crois vraiment on doit pas
opposer l'école publique et l'école
privée depuis la loi Debray du 31
décembre 59 adoptée sous la présidence
du général de Gaulle qui établit la
liberté d'enseignement dans notre pays
notre pays vit et notre pays vit bien
avec des écoles publiques et avec des
écoles privées les premières accueille
100 millions d'élèves les autres 2
millions soit un élève sur 6 et toutes
deux concours au public de l'éducation
dans les établissements privés je le
rappelle les programmes é volume horair
sont ceux du public dans l'ensemble des
établissements sous cont contrat les
enseignants sont rémunérés par l'État et
recrutés avec les mêmes exigences de
qualification que dans le public 50 %
des familles ont eu recours au moins une
fois à l'enseignement privé pour au
moins un de leurs enfants alors je crois
qu'il faut respecter ces choix de
scolarisation ne pas les stigmatiser ne
pas forcer les parents d'élèves à se
justifier mais comprendre ce qu'il y a
derrière leur décision et faire en sorte
que le choix d'une école publique ou le
choix d'une école privée ne soit pas la
résultant de déception ou de frustration
mais qu'elle correspondent ces décisions
à des vrais choix d'adhésion pour tous
au libre arbitre de chacun pour l'école
publique madame la sénatrice j'ai la
plus grande des ambitions d'abord
l'exigence à travers le choc des savoirs
l'autorité renforcée de nos professeurs
à travers toutes les réformme que je
vais poursuivre suite aux impulsions
données par Gabriel Atal sur la
revalorisation des carrières sur les
conditions de travail sur l'organisation
de nos remplacements pour l'école privée
je veux veiller à ce qu'ell soit
toujours épartout au rendez-vous des
principes et des valeurs de la
République et qu'on y renforce aussi
souvent que nécessaire le contrôle
pédagogique et que dans tout notre
service public de l'enseignement on
assure la cohérence de l'offre éducative
et la mixité sociale et
[Musique]
scolaire